i was
one of the most profitable traders in
the whole world at 24 years old
that that shouldn't be possible it
shouldn't be possible
but the reason it is possible is because
if you go onto the training floors
it's entirely populated by people who
only know rich people
so they really their kids
they have no experiential understanding
of the economy
and yet i was one of the only people on
that trading floor
that knew the economy from both sides so
i had such a huge advantage of
understanding how the economy works
i had a really good time at grammar
school i mean you know you were at
school with me i really enjoyed it there
um you'll also be aware i was expelled
from grammar school
um yeah i mean
[Music]
it's quite a possible wouldn't have been
able to get the kind of job that i
eventually got if i didn't go there
uh not because it made me smart or
anything but simply because
it meant that i got in touch with a lot
of people from
better off backgrounds uh you know
mostly in the indian community
who knew how to get these jobs and also
like knew what the good jobs are like i
think
one of the big things that stops smart
kids
from poorer or ordinary backgrounds from
getting the best paid jobs
is simply a straight lack of information
like and that happens
many many steps along the way like first
of all the schools don't inform them
that if you want to get the best job you
need to go to the top uni
and if you want to go to top uni you
need to get these grades i need to get
do these kinds of subjects
so like if you go to an ordinary school
you might get the impression that like
you know
getting a few stars a few ways and a few
bees is really good results and it is
it's much better than average results
but the fact is if you want to come if
you want to compete for the top unis
with kitchener private schools
you need to know you need to get a stars
or aids in every exam i mean you know
that i know that and the indian kids who
went to school with they know that and
they told me that
but ordinary people don't get told that
they don't know that
and then they don't know if you don't
take the right subjects then you're not
going to get in the top unis
and then they're not actually told what
the top unis are
so like one of my a girl who i dated for
a bit really nice girl really smart girl
she went to manchester metropolitan
university right i'm sure it's a great
university
but it's a lot less prestigious than
manchester university
she didn't know that those were
different universities right and nobody
was telling her all right
and this is the kind of lack of
information that people are getting and
like i went to lunch school of economics
right
um and if you that is a super super
prestigious university
if you get into the london school of
economics you have a really good chance
of getting a really good job
but a lot of ordinary people have never
heard of that university
you know they've heard of rocksteady
cambridge but they don't know land
school of economics you know
so it's at every step of the way
ordinary people are not getting the good
information
you need to be told look if you want to
get the best job interviews the best uni
these are the best uni's if you want to
get into juniors you need to get these
kind of grades those kind of grades are
not good enough you get these kinds of
grades they don't get told like
you know the syllabus is online if you
learn this stuff they don't get told
that doing well
exams a lot it's about memorization they
don't get given any of this good
information
and then each step of the way do i
disadvantage that i disadvantage do i
disadvantage
um so going to a grammar school meant
that i was able to get that information
so it really advantaged me um
i mean i'm not an expert on the
education system i guess the argument
would be
that it perhaps disadvantaged
some other kids from poor background who
then didn't have access to me
you know i went to grammar school then i
got expelled
like five or six years later and i went
back to the local comprehensive and i
was back with a lot of kids who went to
primary school with me
and kids were like kind of level with me
in primary school they were a long way
behind then
and it's not because they weren't as
smart as me because back in primary
school they were as smart as me
it's simply the fact that i was
competing with a lot of other smart kids
and i
was aware that you need to get a star in
every subject you know what i mean
so i was just at a high level of
competition and then from these kids not
having access to me
they're disadvantaged in the same way
that i was advantaged by having access
to other smart kids
so that's the argument but um you know
i'm not an expert on education system
right
i enjoyed my time at grammar school
until i expelled which was
not much fun um but then i also enjoyed
my time like a comprehensive
after that and um yeah i don't really
know like
it was it was difficult i became more
aware of
inequality financial inequality and
unfairness and um
it probably put a drive in me that
stayed there for a long time
to prove that kids like me who
talk like me who look like me are not
stupid and then we can do it
and i think that was a big part of the
job that made me successful at
university and later in my job
um so no i mean in the end for me
i'm just glad that i was able to see so
many different things in my childhood
growing up in london growing up around
all people from all different cultures
and then going from grammar school i
also got to see like a variety of
financial backgrounds i wasn't able to
see if i went to comprehensive school
so i just got to see more of like
how many different ways of living that
there are and now i haven't gone to work
in the city
like and i see how how rich some people
are you know what i mean you just see
like
what a ride is and it helps you um i
think as an economist
that's helped me so much because i think
it's actually quite rare nowadays
to meet somebody who has experienced
poverty and has experienced
wealth you won't meet many people like
that in your life unfortunately
because nowadays we live in a world
where largely
people who come from poor backgrounds
don't have the opportunity to become
rich
and people who are born in rich
backgrounds are extremely protected and
will almost certainly stay rich
so what that means then is as an
economist
there's very few people who can actually
understand from experience
the whole economy because most people
have ever spent their whole life being
poor
in which case to be honest they probably
won't be allowed into the conversation
because there's not many people from
poor backgrounds who are in the world of
economics
more often than not it's full of people
who spend their whole lives being rich
and then you can't really be surprised
when somebody who spent their whole life
being rich and it's not just they spend
their whole life being rich
they went to school with people who are
rich they went to university people who
are rich and now they're working people
are rich
you know that probably the only person
they know who's poor is they're cleaner
you know what i mean if they talk to
them
so like these these people like they
live
they live a world of not really
interacting with poor people
so you can't be surprised when they
don't really understand the way that
inequality affects an economy
because they haven't witnessed
inequality they don't really know on a
human personal level
the difference between being poor and
being rich
and poor people and rich people and the
way people behave economically
and the most people spend so i actually
think that
you know i was one of
the most profitable traders in the whole
world at 24 years old
that that shouldn't be possible it
shouldn't be possible
but the reason it is possible is because
if you go onto the training floor
it's entirely populated by people who
only
know rich people so they
really their kids they have no
experiential understanding of the
economy
and yet i was one of the only people on
that trading floor that knew the economy
from both sides
so i had such a huge advantage of
understanding how the economy works
so i think um i'm sort of
lucky to have come from that poor
background and then gotten into that
world and going
into going to grammar school was one of
the reasons why that was able to happen
i guess
people hate bankers and we weight
traders i cannot understand why
i worked a few bankers and i worked for
a few traitors and there's some
unpleasant characters out there
although i should add that i've also
worked with some amazing really really
nice people um
but the truth is that job
is a job that can take you from a poor
background and make you financially
secure and that's what i did for me
um but already since i did it
that job has become one harder to get
focused on ordinary background
like as you know i got that job by
winning a card game you can't do that
nowadays
now you probably need connections or you
need to have a cv that says like
you're a concept pianist who's like
climbed
mount everest you know what i mean and
you can guess what kind of people have
those kind of cvs
so now it's like harder to get that job
and secondly once you get that job
the pay has collapsed like it's not
possible to go in there
and work for like three four years and
smash a load of money and then leave
and try and do like try and do something
else like what i'm doing now
now like you probably have to stick
around for 10 15 20 years to make that
kind of money
so even if i was
10 years younger than i am i would i
wouldn't be able to be sitting here
doing this work i'm doing now i would
need to still be in the bank
so it's even the path that i took
which was a super difficult path even
back then
even that path has been whilst not
closed off it's become much less
accessible people from ordinary
backgrounds and
you know i worked on a trading floor
there's this stereotype of the sort of
cockney geezer wild boy
the truth is almost everyone who worked
as a trader on a trading floor from a
top bank
um comes from a relatively privileged
background so even that path
working in finance which
is one of the most feasible parts out of
poverty
has almost been closed off now so i
think it has gone worse
ordinary people see they get like a kind
of stereotyped
image of how rich people live from tv
and instagram and this kind of stuff
that's more visible but i think richer
people
don't get such a good understanding of
how ordinary people live because
that kind of way of life is not it's not
really glamorized they're not really
shown
and also i think unfortunately a lot of
wealthy people just don't really care
because ordinary people aspire to be
rich right but rich people don't aspire
to be
ordinary people right rich people tend
to be you know i remember when i quit my
job and um
you know i'm aware i'm phenomenally
lucky to have made the money that i made
right and i made in whatever five or six
years more money than
my parents made in their entire careers
like much much more
but then when i quit the people at the
bank really really didn't want me to
quit
and one of the big senior bosses sat me
down and he said that amount of money
you made it's nothing
it's you're going to want you're going
to bri it's going to run out and you're
going to need more in like a couple of
years
yeah and i was just thinking
it's just crazy what a distorted
understanding of the world and of money
a lot of these very rich people have
because you know my my parents raised
a family of three kids for you know
less than you know a quarter of what i
don't in
that you know time they raise the whole
family you know live the whole life on
that
and they think i'm gonna run out you
know and but it's just um
when unfortunately it's like i said
increasingly
rich people they live in quite a
closeted world right they
they go they send their kids to private
schools then they go to the elite
universities and then they get elite
jobs
and they only know other rich people so
often they don't think they're rich
because they compare themselves to
people around them and they have a
tendency to compare themselves to people
who are a bit richer than them
so they just think like oh yeah i'm a
bit richer than maybe
there's common throwbacks i'm not that
rich you know this guy's got more than
me it's like classic keeping up with the
joneses you know what i mean
so they i mean
that that is why to be frank i'm such a
better economist than them
because they have a distorted image of
reality that comes from the distorted
the extremely closeted part of the world
that they see and that comes from
inc that comes from this um complete
separation we have of ordinary people in
the rich they go to
different schools different universities
they get different jobs and then
what is most problematic is in these
really powerful jobs like
economics like trading in the city
government
it becomes only populated by this class
of super rich people who have no idea
what the ordinary world is like
and then you can't be surprised when
their predictions are always wrong and
the outcome is always bad because
ultimately these guys have not been
chosen because they're the best
they've been chosen because they're from
the right families so we're not getting
the smartest people in the top jobs
and then you can't be surprised when we
have an incompetent government
and you can't be surprised when we have
terrible human outcomes
you know if you destroy social mobility
a direct consequence of that is
unintelligent people in top jobs that's
obvious right
if the best people were in the best jobs
then they've come from all throughout
society
but right now they all come from the
same schools and the same families so
we're wasting like 90 percent of the
population
and then it's it's a drive towards
incompetence and it's a drive towards
idiocy
and you know i went to oxford university
to a masters
it drove me mad the level of
incompetence and lack of understanding
from these powerful professors
they've got no idea what ordinary
people's lives are like and they don't
care
because they're getting paid it doesn't
affect them
we've created a generation of young men
who have had
wealth and financial success
shove down their throats for their whole
childhoods and have no legitimate means
of getting those things
there is one other thing they can do
with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mom's house